les habitants de ces départements ne
pourront plus sortir de chez eux sans
attestation de 18h à 6h du matin les
hautes-alpes alpes-maritimes ardennes le
doubs le jura la marne haute marne
meurthe et moselle la meuse haute saône
les vosges le territoire de belfort la
moselle la nièvre et la saône-et-loire
sont les quinze départements concernés
leur taux d'incidence le nombre de cas
sur cent mille habitants étant supérieur
à 250 selon le porte parole du
gouvernement
ce durcissement des mesures peut
ralentir l'épidémie
ce que nous disent les scientifiques
c'est que le couvre-feu fonctionne celui
qui avait été mis en place avant le 2è
confinement au mois d'octobre a eu des
effets importants
quand vous mettez en place un couvre-feu
vous limitez les interactions sociales
que l'on peut avoir dans un cercle privé
et on sait que c'est par là que le virus
se diffuse le plus en avançant à 18h par
définition vous limiter encore plus ces
rencontres un avis qui n'est pas partagé
par le maire de metz je regrette
profondément cette décision et j'avais
dit au préfet que qu'il ne fallait pas
la prendre parce que les bénéfices
seraient nulles et les inconvénients
sont énormes
la seule solution qui marche c'est le
confinement le vrai comme en mars avril
celui qui fait que tous les salariés qui
ne sont pas absolument indispensable
mais aussi des collégiens les lycéens
les étudiants restent à la maison et ça
ça fonctionne pour que les français
concernés puissent se préparer à cette
avancée du couvre-feu quelque peu
contraignante une certaine tolérance
sera appliqué les premiers jours selon
le porte parole les attestations restent
les mêmes l'amande forfaitaire de 135
euros en cas de non respect des mesures
aussi un nouveau point sur l'avancée de
l'épidémie ce sera fait le 7 janvier
soit dans moins d'une semaine